>> Tucker: PROBABLY THE MOST
HIGH PROFILE ROUTINE
BRIEFING ROOM ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL STATE.
REMARKABLE EXCHANGES.
SHEAR PART OF IT?
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE IS FIT
FOR DUTY.
>> ABSOLUTELY FIT FOR DUTY.
>> WHAT DOES HIS PLAN LOOK
LIKE.
LIMITED TO ONE SCOOP OF ICE
CREAM NOW.
>> I DON'T LIMIT HIS DIET AT
ALL.
>> SOME PEOPLE HAVE
SUGGESTED THAT COULD BE
RELATED TO DENTURES.
DOES THE PRESIDENT WEAR
DENTURES.
>> HE DOES NOT.
>> DID YOU ADDRESS DRUG
ADDICTION.
>> YEAH.
>> ANY OTHER DRUGS?
>> HE HAS NO DRUG ADDICTION,
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO ME HOW
A GUY WHO EATS MCDONALD'S
AND KENTUCKY FRIED CHICKEN
AND ALL THOSE COKES IS AS IN
GOOD A SHAPE AS HE IS IN.
>> IT'S CALLED GWINNETT
PARTICULARS.
>>
PARTICULAR.
>> Tucker: DOES THE THEATER
SAY MUCH ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
OR THE PRESS?
FOX NEWS POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
IF TRUMP RUNS AGAIN AND I
WAS IN CHARGE, I WON'T BE.
IF I WERE I WOULD JUST RUN A
TAPE OF REPORTERS ASKING
DOES HE WEAR DENTURES?
WHAT'S HIS LIFE EXPECTANCY?
WHAT'S HIS WAIST
CIRCUMFERENCE?
I THINK THAT WOULD GET HIM
ELECTED.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT,
TUCKER, HE GOT A PRETTY
CLEAN BILL OF HEALTH THAT'S
FOR SURE.
PART OF THIS IS THE FUNCTION
THE FACT THAT HE TOLD
PREVIOUSLY THE DOCTOR TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH AND
ENJOY AS VERY HIGH ENREN
STATION.
HE TOLD HIM TO GO OUT AND
NOT REFUSE ANY QUESTIONS.
ANSWER ALL QUESTIONS.
THE PRESS SEEING THIS IS
ONE EXCHANGE OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS WAIST LINE AND ALL
THAT THEY DIDN'T MEASURE HIS
WAIST LINE BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO REASON TO DO IT.
>> Tucker: IS HE NOT A
EVERYTHING THE CURRENT FUROR
OVER HIS MENTAL CONDITION,
THE PRESIDENT HAD ASKED
ALTHOUGH IT WASN'T
CLINICALLY INDICATED THAT
THIS DOCTOR GIVE HIM A
BECAUSE HE GOT 30 QUESTIONS
OUT OF 30 CORRECT.
THAT HIS COGNITIVE FACULTIES
ARE VERY MUCH IN ORDER AND
THAT HE IS SHARP AND ON IT
AND COHERENT.
NOW, THAT'S NOT A
PSYCHIATRIC EXAM.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED.
BUT IT'S A PRETTY GOOD TEST
AND HE PASSED THAT WITH
FLYING COLORS.
THERE WAS SOME, YOU COULD
DETECT A CERTAIN SKEPTICISM
AND DISAPPOINTMENT IN THE
ROOM ABOUT IT.
THE DOCTOR WAS PRETTY
EMPHATIC AND TO ANY FAIR
MINDED VIEWER PRETTY
CONVINCING.
>> Tucker: I REMEMBER DURING
THE LAST PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN WHEN HILLARY
CLINTON HAD SOME KIND OF
COLLAPSE IN NEW YORK, I
THINK IT WAS ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11.
WE WERE EXPLICITLY
INSTRUCTED BY "THE
WASHINGTON POST" NOT TO ASK
ABOUT HER HEALTH.
WHEN DID THE RULES CHANGE?
>> WELL, I THINK WE DID END
>> I DID.
AND THERE WAS NOT A LOT OF
ANSWERS FORTHCOMING.
AND, YOU KNOW, TO BE
PERFECTLY FAIR ABOUT IT,
TUCKER, ONE IS ENTITLED TO
HAVE A CONFIDENTIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH ONE'S
DOCTORS ABOUT YOUR MENTAL
PRESIDENT I HAVE EVER HEARD
OF COURSE WE KNOW IF WE GO
BACK FAR ENOUGH YOU COME
ACROSS PRESIDENTS LIKE
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT WHO
CONCEALED HIS PARALYSIS TO
THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
SO MOST AMERICANS DID NOT
KNOW ABOUT IT UNTIL AFTER HE
WAS DEAD.
THE PRESS WAS COMPLICIT IN
THAT ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
REPORTERS WHO COVERED HIM
KNEW IT BUT NEVER REPORTED
IT.
THAT'S HOW MUCH THE
STAGE IT'S OPEN SEASON.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT
OBVIOUSLY FELT IF THESE
QUESTIONS WERE GOING TO BE
RAISED AND IS IN REMARKABLY
GOOD HEALTH GOOD GENES A MAN
WHO IS 71, 6'3", 239 POUNDS.
HE WAS PARTLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS.
THE THING WENT ON FOR 56
MINUTES.
WHICH REALLY HAVE
UNPRECEDENTED.
>> Tucker: IT REALLY WAS
FORENSIC.
UNBELIEVABLE.
BRIT HUME, THANK YOU.